we're comic-con is over I am back home
and if there is one thing that I have
seen the head them in vigor unlike
anything I've ever seen it's my Twitter
feed about Batman V Superman and a
couple other trailers that we'll get to
we'll start with the ones that you
didn't get in high def so train it for
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice hid
comic-con showed us a bunch of new [ __ ]
it was really good scene that hooked me
is right the beginning of this trailer
in this movie zombie Superman is under
some scrutiny because he's this rip tony
and alien god and people are like that
freaks us out because we're fleshy
little humans he could wipe us all out
we've seen him wipe out half a city when
he was fighting Zod not really his fault
and he didn't do much in the way of
damage control but the point is these
two Titans collided and metropolis paid
the price and I was like hey talk with
us a bit man it's a lot of power and
we're kind of scared but Bruce Wayne was
in Metropolis when that [ __ ] was going
down and at one point the heat visions
going everywhere just cuts this building
in half from the inside and that was a
Wayne tower I guess and people died
Bruce Wayne was there when this thing is
following it was when Ben athletes just
hauling ass into the dust Club into the
9/11 of Metropolis that dust cloud just
hits him he just didn't stop I was like
yeah that's that's what Batman would do
that's why I love Batman because like
he's mortal but the [ __ ] yeah he's gonna
go right in there cuz I was always
taking lies Batman vs Superman but what
would make Batman so like no this guy
needs to be stopped but seeing that he
was there he saw the destruction he saw
the carnage that would kind of bring you
over to that side and I love that you
kind of get the feeling Bruce Wayne has
not been Batman for many years and if
you saw that once too that had all the
Joker riding on it that looks like a
Robin outfit probably Jason Todd there's
a scene in The Suicide Squad trailer
that might tie into that we'll talk
about that in that video I think the
story is Jason Todd was killed Bruce
Wayne stop being Batman he's like you
know what no more he hasn't been Batman
since I think this is the thing that
Bruce Wayne saw and he's like nope
Batman's not done he has more work to do
I gotta take this dude down because he
has the power to destroy the entire
human race he must be stopped but what I
love is that Alfred there's one thing
he's like you're going to war he is not
our enemy but Batman doesn't care he's
like no he is point is I'm loving how
this looks although there's not one
scene where Lex Luthor's talking he's
like this is God versus man day versus
night
it shows action [ __ ] happening it's just
Batman get up and then he does a
grappling hook thing and he moves
Superman's heat vision is just like boom
Batman moves just in time to miss his
heat vision which hits right where he
was and I was like super
tried to kill Batman just now Batman
move so he didn't die but the point of
Superman was like and right BAM Batman
didn't move he would be dead it is white
kill Zod sounds like I'm gonna kill the
people that you know cuz I'm going to
but there are a couple things to note in
this trailer that I'm not really sold on
first of all Jesse Eisenberg as Lex
Luthor people are always like what do
you think now every time there's a bit
of news people like haha like it's
different I was always like Jesse
Eisenberg I don't see his Lex Luthor
because I feel like he's going to be
Jesse Eisenberg playing Lex Luthor but
he's still gonna be Jesse Eisenberg and
if you look at Lex Luthor and Jesse
Eisenberg they just aren't the same and
then that picture where he was bald hit
the Internet people were like what what
do you think of that I'm like it looks
like bald Jesse Eisenberg still not sold
I need to see him in the trailer and now
I saw him in the trailer and people were
like shut what do you think yeah I think
as plainly as I can put it Jesse
Eisenberg acts exactly how I thought
Jesse Eisenberg as Lex Luthor would act
I wasn't sold on it before and I'm not
sold on it now and that's really to the
point because I was like I know what
they're trying to do with Jesse
Eisenberg as Lex Luthor I just think
it's a dumb ass day because every line
Jesse Eisenberg says in this trailer Ike
envisioned Lex Luthor as I do know him
delivering that line I'm like yeah it
just makes it way better in this trailer
he acts like a really rich weird
socially awkward dude good acts like how
I think Riddler or calendar man or
Jervis Tetch would act but not really
Lex Luthor and the trailer does start to
get a little clogging I thought gal
gadot as Wonder Woman good thing is when
I saw her as Wonder Woman I was like you
didn't disappoint me as Wonder Woman
that's good I think she looks good she
might kick ass in the movie maybe she
will be good it's all about act I want
to see how she acts in the trailer there
was no dialogue spoken by her so we just
don't know maybe they're trying to hide
it but it is where the trailer started
feeling a bit crowded I was like wow you
got that man and Superman you got Lex
Luthor you have Wonder Woman it is truly
dawn of Justice but holy [ __ ] I just
kind of want to see Batman vs Superman I
want to see God versus man cuz that's
kind of what it is obviously some [ __ ]
in this movies out of context that scene
at the end we rip the doors off the
Batmobile off you know he's like boom
wraps them off he's like are you okay
Bruce that looks like a really bad wreck
goods are loose I was uh texting Alfred
Oh keep in the end guys I'm really
pumped for Batman V Superman this trail
look cool it showed a lie this is a long
trail I don't want them to show too much
I feel like they should cut it off here
in Berlin alright stop that's what we
have now show is a couple of TV spots
and let the movie come out what I like
about this it's a long trailer but
there's nothing in context I don't know
what the plot is really than the fact
that people are freaked out they're kind
of putting Superman on a metaphorical if
not actual trial and Batman wants to
kick his ass and Lex Luthor's a weirdo
kid all right guys so Batman or Superman
whose side are you on what do we think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more